[Musique]
bienvenue sur ce plateau en
collaboration avec l'université des
mères qui a lieu cette année de façon un
peu différente vous le savez sous le nom
de mr il ya plusieurs fonctions il fait
évidemment il ya des maires de grandes
villes il ya des maires de petites
communes
est ce que ce sont les mêmes mais le
métier est ce que ce sont les mêmes
façons d'exercer cette fonction c'est ce
dont nous allons parler avec nos invités
denis larguero bonjour bonjour une de 12
depuis dix-sept bertrand oyo bonjour le
maire de magny les hameaux
depuis 2000 nous je crois et puis bruno
millièmes bonjour bonjour député modem
9e circonscription des yvelines et vous
êtes un spécialiste de la ruralité si je
peux dire des justement d'aider des
maires ruraux
alors on va parler justement de la
ruralité de l'urbanisation aussi mais
peut-être un mood d'actualité d'abord
sur la situation sanitaire parce que les
mères ont été vraiment en première ligne
dans cette gestion de crise
il y a eu de nouvelles mesures un
confinement qui ne n'est pas tout à fait
vain puisque on peut beaucoup sortir
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt se protéger et
sortir en même temps les uns et les
autres qu'est ce que vous pensez de ces
mesures est ce qu est ce que c'est ça
qu'il fallait faire ce qui est une bonne
solution
les deux nil pardon non disons que là on
est dans le dans le décryptage en fait à
pour pour nos populations de d'un
confinement effectivement qui a été
compris tout de suite non c'est dans sa
déclinaison pratique mais qui
mais qui sur le fond laisse en tous les
cas pour nos zones très denses
métropolitaine des possibilités de
deux sorties des possibilités de
profiter en fait du plein air et de la
météo en l'occurrence de mitaines qui a
été a été bonne et spécialement à meudon
où on a comme vous le savez la moitié du
territoire qui est une forêt d'avoir pu
profiter en fait de la possibilité de
sortir après on va voir dans la
déclinaison cette semaine des modalités
de travail comment les comment les
choses vont s'organiser et c'est vrai
que c'est du côté des commerces qu'on a
le plus d'incompréhension puisqu'il ya
effectivement une inégalité de
traitement entre certains commerces qui
restent ouverts d'autres qui sont qui
sont fermés et c'est vrai que moi j'ai
eu plutôt ce week end et des retours de
commerçants qui ne comprenaient pas les
distinctions qui pouvait être fait entre
certains montrent voilà après du côté
des du côté des habitants plutôt à un
accueil plutôt favorable par rapport à
une crainte qui était celle de se
retrouver dans le les conditions du
premier confinement qui a été vraiment
très très compliqué à à à subir bien
trop brouillon la problématique et
surtout la situation la situation
sanitaire sur lequel on est et avec
beaucoup d'interrogations finalement sur
les perspectives sur les prochaines
semaines il ya eu des alertes en tout
cas qu'on a tous entendu dans les médias
depuis fin janvier
maintenant voilà il ya un confinement
qui on n'est pas forcément un comme
comme le dit un collègue de meudon on a
passé le week-end à essayer de
comprendre de quoi il s'agissait
je reviendrai pas sur l'attestation
autour de ça et voilà on a passé ce
week-end à ça on a une horreur qu'on
prend sur en effet de la part d'un
certain nombre de petits commerces sur
sur nos partie rurale et puis et puis le
sentiment qu'on ne demande pas assez
d'être en télétravail au niveau de
l'entreprise aussi au delà du
au-delà du fait de demander de faire des
efforts on a l'impression qu'il n'y a
pas forcément beaucoup de à beaucoup
d'engagement de ce côté là voilà certes
certes on a toujours la possibilité de
sortir et tant mieux et encore plus dans
nos zones rurales où quand on sort on
croise quand même beaucoup de monde
beaucoup moins de monde qu'en milieu
urbain
on est ravi parce que les forêts ne sont
pas interdites c'était le cas l'année
dernière
on va voir à l'usagé
parce que ce que ça va devenir sur cette
rue après je vous avoue que au delà de
la au delà de la pédagogie et
l'explication de texte à faire pour
aider les habitants en ce moment on est
beaucoup plus diriger sur
l'accompagnement pour la vaccination
bien sûr mais c'est essentiel bruno
médiane c'est vrai que quand on voit
bien et se dire qu'il faut il faut agir
au au jour le jour à l'heure leurs
précédentes rencontres sont mus et il
faut on est dans la dentelle là donc
c'est extraordinairement compliquée
parce que si on se remémore le début de
l'année les moulins ont il y avait un
effet de sidération et mons à l'élu en
fermant tous on allait mal et quand même
ralentir voir instaurer on n'a pas
stoppé malheureusement complètement la
pandémie mais en tout cas on a beaucoup
ralenti
c'est la méthode effectivement la crise
efficace mais elle a des effets pervers
derrière on l'a tous eu l adsu car vers
économique bien évidemment elle a des
effets pervers sur la santé
psychologique et psychique des gens ça
on l'a constaté au fur et à mesure du
temps on a malgré tout réussi à
maintenir les écoles alors contre vents
et marées un je vous dis quand même
c'est pas un c'est pas évident mais on a
bien vu que sur la première période les
écoles scharner c'était aussi un
problème
et puis là on essaye de faire quelque
chose qui est un peu inédit et qui
repose encore une fois sur ce qui avait
été jouée au mas janvier c'est à dire
sur la responsabilité de tout un chacun
on sait que la seule protection un
vaccin
aujourd'hui c'est quand même les gestes
barrière le masque etc
ça me permet aussi aux gens
effectivement là on a entraînement le
printemps ça aurait pu
deux shows mais honnêtement germé charme
et de france et autres france
clairement je vois pas comment effectuer
impossible deschamps serait sorti de
toute façon on va passer notre temps à
mettre des amendes aux gens donc on est
simplement là dedans effectivement la
responsabilisation et dire je vous la
voulez sortir vous pouvez vous produisez
vous pouvez respirer après il faut qu'on
fasse attention une autre famille je
sais que ça devient de plus en plus
difficile moi je vois dans ma petite
commune rurale dès les trois premiers
jours de beau temps qui a eu
bizarrement il y avait beaucoup plus de
voitures devant chacune des habitations
donc ça veut dire que les gens nous
accueillir deux personnes il faut faire
excessivement attention quand on fait ça
je dis pas qu'il faut cacher parce que
c'est humain il faut qu'on soit
conscient on n'a rien d'autre
aujourd'hui en vaccins pour se protéger
et que c'est distanciation sanitaires
alors parlons un peu de votre deux roues
vite de votre métier de mai on va
peut-être commencer par me dos déni
larguero vous le disiez c'est une ville
urbania ya presque cinquante mille
habitants à meudon
mais 50% du territoire s'est déplacé la
forêt donc est ce que vous considérez
vous que vous êtes une crue wind
urbaines que rurales d'ailleurs je pense
qu'on est de plus en plus des communes
hybrides ou ou mixtes si je puis dire
puisque meudon et bon exemple vous
l'avais dit en termes de répartition du
du territoire mais je pense que de plus
en plus nos communes métropolitaines
s'oriente vers une gestion hybride et la
volonté effectivement de faire revenir
la nature la biodiversité en ville et
donc c'est ce qui nous rapproche de nos
collègues des la ruralité c'est le terme
que vous avez employé et de fait à
meudon nous avons comme comme partenaire
très régulier l'office national des
forêts par exemple qui est aussi
j'imagine un partenaire de nos de nos
collègues en milieu en milieu rural nous
avons effectivement les lieux de
rencontre
talus sncf que nous allons reprendre en
gestion en termes d'un accord que nous
avons signé la semaine dernière nous
avons de plus en plus de deux zones que
nous allons consacrer à d opération de
reconquête de friches très clairement et
avec l'objectif de faire revenir très
très visiblement très concrètement la
nature en ville que ce soit au travers
de de la revégétalisation des cours
d'école de l'agriculture urbaine de
toutes ces possibilités que nous avons
aujourd'hui que nous saisissons au
travers de swat de nos partenaires que
je viens de citer soit au travers bien
sûr de décision purement municipal donc
c'est je pense une tendance lourde comme
on dit que de pouvoir se réapproprier
ces sujets et oui par exemple j'ai
souhaité que meudon maintenant adhère à
la fédération des devil forestière de
manière à ce qu'on puisse bénéficier de
l'expérience de nos collègues dans la
gestion de de ses sujets et qu'on puisse
avoir des liens des échanges avec le
collègue des villes ou villages ruraux
de manière à pouvoir nous nous enrichir
aussi de leurs de leur expérience et je
crois qu'on a vraiment beaucoup à y
gagner en tous les cas c'est ccma c'est
ma conviction et et nos services
bien sûr travaille dans ce sens
réfléchissent dans ce sens battre en
voyant on pourrait peu à peu près
définir la ddt un peu de la même façon
magny les hameaux au fond il ya en effet
ils sont urbains mais il ya aussi vous
appartenez au parc de la vallée de
chevreuse
il ya ces deux dimensions aussi dans
votre ville s'est faite plus tôt
d'ailleurs une ville rurale qui s'est
urbanisée d'ailleurs dans l'histoire on
a beaucoup moins d'habitants cac à
meudon donc plus petites communes 1,9
1500 habitants et c'est vrai que plus de
70% de notre territoire et
et en zone naturelle ou agricole et puis
c'est 60 contre toute possibilité
d'étalement urbain dans le cadre
notamment du parc naturel régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse ou bien des
zones naturelles préexistantes et natura
et c'est vrai que grande partie de la
population 6 heures
il ya besoin de tous les services pour
la gloire aussi en vidéo à la fois pour
les habitants qui va permettre aux
services enfants à l'ensemble des
services d'accompagnement de la famille
de m
en accompagnant nos la contraignant en
développant l'agriculture client en lui
les deux sens permettant laissé un gros
sera l'occasion manning et fait des
ravages et permettant aux habitants
directement fatale de m la démocrate
ruth mellal et servir dans les termes
local de milliane justement content
qu'on regarde c'est de cette ville et
mis la main sur des différences on a
peut-être la pression que ça pourrait
être ça un peu la france de l'avenir
avec la transition écologique avec
justement ce mix entre l'urbanisme et la
ruralité
si les maires se montrent tout seul il
est rentré notamment avec nero citoyen
mrc dans des communes de moins de 1000
habitants pour être clair mais c'est ça
c'est très très compliqué donc vous avez
deux façons de faire visite vous avez la
passion un petit peu changé ces dix
bombes h à son moi je me remets ce qui
est une manière un petit peu de
d'abandonner le terrain à mon sens mais
c'est très compliqué je comprends
certains maires le fasse et vidéos qui
sont très volontaires ou encore qui
veulent aller beaucoup plus loin et cela
ils ont besoin d'une vraie solidarité
commune un petit peu plus grandes comme
celle devait retrouver par exemple et
encore comme celle de denis verdier pour
travailler ensemble il faut créer cette
espèce de maillage qui va de menon
engendre à magny les hameaux et à des
petites communes comme j'aimais mois sur
le territoire presque essentiellement
parce qu'à part les numéros qui est
étudiée l'éthique de la ville
tout le reste ce sont quasiment qu elles
sont plus grandes que nous ont certes
mais j'ai énormément de l'onu invitant
absolument vrai et c'est parce que c'est
sans doute un des avenirs possibles de
nos sociétés est ce que on l'avait vu
avec la crise du gilet jaune
il ya une fracture sociale il y avait
aussi une fracture territoriale est ce
que je pense qu'à me do je ne sais pas
si vous souffrirez de cette fracture
territoriale est ce que vous la sentez
en tout cas ce que parfois on vous l'a
on vous dit qu'elle existe alors c'est
vrai que on peut avoir effectivement le
sentiment de bénéficier d'un niveau de
service qui est très supérieur par
rapport à d'autres zones
tout ça est quand même en train de
s'équilibrer on voit bien que nous nous
avons les mêmes difficultés en terme de
population médicale par exemple
notamment sur les médecins généralistes
le la zone de déficit en terme de
population médicale elle commence à la
première couronne et dès qu'on dépasse
les villes qui sont immédiatement
limitrophe de paris vous a commencé à
avoir des problèmes de démographie
médicale par exemple un de nos projets
bidons c'est effectivement là la
création d'une maison santé parce que
nous avons une population médicale
fortement décline des clients nous avons
co financé avec la région d'ailleurs la
maison médicale à meudon la forêt nous
jouons maintenant en créer une à
nouzonville
on nous assurer que demain nous aurons
une population médicale notamment
médecins généralistes qui pourra
adresser nos besoins en termes de
médecine généraliste dont on voit que
cette fracture territoriale elle et elle
est tout aussi j'ai envie de dire
franche ou inégalitaire qu'elle a pu
être à un moment donné vous voyez un
certain nombre de populations qui du
fait de confinement du fait du
développement du télétravail est une
bonne chose
rechercher vont aller s'installer à
magny les hameaux dans les prochains
mois ou années j'en compte absolument
pas comme déjà elles sont elles le fuit
depuis paris vers mme dont et ensuite
sans doute lorsque les enfants de plus
nombre et la ville vont sans doute se
décaler vers nos amis des yvelines et
c'est pour ça qu'on travaille d'ailleurs
département 78 80 de cette manière très
très rapprochés pour aussi adresser les
problématiques qui sont celles de la
connexion entre nos entrepreneurs
collectivités de manière à pouvoir
faciliter la cigale et le traitement de
ces deux sais pas ce qu'on peut appeler
des ruptures territoriales mais que nous
mener sur lesquels nous travaillons
fortement et sur lesquels je crois on a
fait beaucoup de progrès à bourges je
prends l'exemple et pour terminer un peu
anecdotique mais qui est très symbolique
parce qu'ils font que
très très bien à meudon c'est la
reconversion d'un kiosque presse vous
savez qu'ils étaient vite depuis deux
ans parce que la presse maintenant eh
bien elle se vend principalement par
internet on trouve on ne trouve plus de
personnes qui sont prêtes à faire ce
travail de kiosque et en tous les cas on
n'a qu'un kiosque actifs radio dont le
deuxième il était vide depuis deux ans
et bien c'est un jeune centralien qui a
monté une entreprise qui reconfigurer
les kiosques en en clayette ça s'appelle
la clayette et qui vous permet donc
d'acheter des produits bio et produits
donc qui met à proximité en fait en
circuit court de ces kiosques et qui
donc fait vivre des maraîchers de la
région ile-de-france qui y vendent leurs
produits à l'intérieur de ce 2 de ce
kiosque et qui fait un résultat
incroyable qui marche très très bien et
qui va sans doute en installer un
deuxième là il est entré dans son camion
rouge et cette gosse que qui aujourd'hui
s'en sent vide dans nos mines exploitées
dans un certain nombre de nos communes
et là il va les transformer en lieux de
vente pour des produits qui sont
justement produit dans les yvelines par
exemple qu'est-ce qu'il ya beaucoup de
maraîchers ou ferme qui peuvent qui
peuvent alimenter ses ses caisses que
dans nos zones métropolitaines et c'est
un exemple certes symbolique mais j'en
écris aujourd'hui une preuve de succès
en tous les cas très concrète à meudon
puisque ça y est il a créé ces deux
premiers en sport pour alimenter la
machine au kiosque qui aujourd'hui il
délivre de manière extrêmement
significative et les premiers supports
sont à la clé c'est formidable ça parce
qu'il ya à la fois on risque d'avoir du
mal de trouver médecins qui veulent
s'installer à meudon
c'est incroyable mais oui je vous le dit
et ses innovations
ces estimations qui vous ont changé on
est ami bertrand guillon vous aussi sur
cette dure
territoriales il ya des points sur
lesquels vous sentez affaibli faire leur
propre langue
les propos de mme dernier rôle par
rapport à la présence la médecine de
proximité
pas forcément si on a vécu d'autres qui
disent carrément dans nos zones rurales
on va dire perry jordan arrive aussi en
milieu plusieurs mois aujourd'hui a déjà
travaillé sur ce sujet des années et en
comptant avec avec les collègues
n'avaient sur eux du fait de la présence
musicale
il a fait cap estrada 6 novembre avec un
hôpital local pour pouvoir avoir de
médecin réaliser directement sur les
sept fois dans sa vie prendre forme et
c'est ça fonctionne et ça permet de
répondre justement à des besoins tout
simplement normaux de la population et
lui éviter de faire des dizaines de
kilomètres pour pouvoir accéder à
l'offre médicale
ensuite on en termes de fracture sur sur
notre secteur c'est principalement une
fracture en termes de transport et là
encore avec l'ensemble des collègues de
notre territoire on on essaye de faire
avancer la compréhension des des
autorités de transport pour pouvoir
prendre en compte les besoins de nos
populations plus rural et qui doivent se
rendre notamment au travail alors certes
en ce moment c'est beaucoup de
télétravail tant mieux ça évite un
certain nombre de nécessité de transport
mais rien que par exemple pour nos
lycéens pour pour aller au lycée qui
était à guyancourt
pour faire cette dizaine de kilomètres
il faut se battre pour avoir des bus qui
soit adaptée en fonction du nombre
d'élèves qui sont à transporter donc
tout ça doit
doit devenir un vrai progrès pour
pouvoir permettre que à l'échelle de
l'ensemble de notre région on puisse
avoir ce sentiment d'appartenance et et
ce lien direct qui évite un moment donné
aussi d'utiliser la voiture puisque
c'est aussi un un cadre de transition
après on essaye dans nos dans nos
communes et c'est moins facile dans les
communes plus rurales que la nôtre parce
qu'encore jeune 2500 habitants des moins
qu'au même mois ruraux mais on essaye
dans une commune comme la nôtre pour
éviter aussi de prendre trop de
transport d'avoir l'ensemble des
services et notamment en termes de
commerce directement sur place
on a travaillé avec une initiative avec
le parc naturel régional de la vallée de
chevreuse sur un système s'appelle la
boutique à l'essai et qui permet
d'accompagner des porteurs de projets
pour tester leur projet et s'installer
de manière plus durable et réussir
finalement leur installation sur le
territoire on va on va ouvrir la
deuxième prochainement la première
fonctionne maintenant depuis plus de 3
ou 4 ans et et c'est superbe
dans ce cadre là bruno milian parce
qu'ils doivent plus malheureusement
beaucoup beaucoup de temps justement le
rôle d'un député nous allons lui disiez
vous êtes d un élu d'une circonscription
rurale est ce que je le député aussi
peut-être un porte parole d'eads et des
merdes de la ruralité justement qui sont
parfois quand on va faire du mal à se
faire entendre
vous savez depuis la fin du cumul des
mandats c'est une question que se sont
posée tous les défilés j'espère et voilà
comment il voulait écouler
conduire leurs actions de manière à ce
que ça déficit au territoire alors par
petites touches mais d'une manière
générale mais moi j'ai entretenu des
rapports et là je dois rendre hommage au
maire de méricourt si léger soir qui a
été un soutien incroyable et j'ai essayé
de porter autant que faire se peut le
revoir
je vous prends juste un exemple la loi
de sébastien lecornu leurs engagements
et proximité un certain nombre de
mesures et qui sont dans cette loi
vienne des travaux vont être conduits
avec le merlot de ma circonscription
donc voilà je reste j'essaye de rester
le maximum en contact avec eux parce que
j'ai besoin de cette heure mon terrain
j'ai le genre aussi de sentir en dehors
effectivement deux déplacements sur le
territoire mais qui sont souvent des
déplacements des cérémonies etc
on essaye de faire les foins
excessivement régulier lancement ça que
le plus compliqué parce que ça se passe
par les yeux c'est beaucoup moins
conviviale
mais avant la longue vie pour vous
donner un exemple tous les mois il ya
une réunion avec les maires 1 comment un
mâle terme à nantes et on avance
ensemble et on sortait des idées on
transmettait tout le monde je vais faire
un petit point si vous permettez patrice
et sans être long sur la fracture
territoriale et la fracture territoriale
on l'a vu on a entendu parler du désert
médical mais ça j'espère que les déserts
médicaux il va falloir qu'on trouve de
solution parce que c'est pas simplement
d'avoir supprimé le numerus clausus qui
va changer les choses il faut aussi que
les nouveau-nés sas a et sur les
territoires a peut-être trouvé des
façons sur leur dernière à notre
formation d'aller vers les territoires
les plus enclavées et en général toutes
les expériences sont menées il reste
donc un bon espoir
mais elle est surtout et avant tout pour
moi c'est une fille et une fracture la
fracture sociale et territoriale parce
que sur les territoires de curé on a
alors de les vider domaine de l'éco du
depuis des années on a trop metropolis
et l'économie hees a obligé les gens est
finalement allé vers les métropoles
qu'on travaille de la transition
écologique devrait nous permettre de
ramener d'économies sur les territoires
il y aura un certain nombre des taux à
desserrer pour pouvoir différents sans
que ces petites communes se sont déjà
vives mais il faut qu'on arrive à créer
une espèce de de maillage fin du
territoire même avec des pme dédié peu
pour les mêmes les aider à s'installer
et retraités jamais
les territoires de manière à voir
quelque chose de plus harmoniser que ce
qu'on a en ce moment parce que c'est
compliqué effectivement pour les
territoires nos voilà on y travaille
c'est compliqué ces bassins il ya des
freins un petit peu partout mais il faut
qu'on arrive à le laisser sera l'un pour
pour carnet ce genre de mutation on va
dire territoriale venir à linverse eu ce
qu'on a fait jusqu'à maintenant c'est à
dire l'inversé la métropolisation maman
il le temps du ressac est arrivé il
faudrait rejeter de l'économie sur les
têtes on voit qu'il ya beaucoup d
d'innovation possible de changements
possibles beaucoup d'espoir possible il
nous reste très peu de temps lol j'ai
juste vous demander au bar trouillot et
c'est l'arrêt roe est ce que vous êtes
des mers heureux je suis pleinement
heureux de pouvoir travailler à agir au
niveau local avec les habitants de notre
commune et on a la chance d'être dans
une collectivité où beaucoup de monde se
connaît où il ya un tissu associatif qui
est qui et fort une solidarité qui est
qui est incroyable et on fait tout
ensemble en fait donc forcément voilà
c'est c'est une joie de voir avancer
notre commune de voir se développer un
certain nombre de services d équipement
et qu'on arrive encore plus en ce moment
à passer cette période de crise
en serrant les coudes les les uns les
autres et au delà de ça avec l'ensemble
des collègues du territoire puisqu'on
est une association des maires de notre
canton avec lesquels on discute très
régulièrement et on échange sur les
problématiques qu'on peut avoir
sarr jour un petit peu ce que ce qui
évoquait justement bruno de bruno
millièmes sur les les liens entre des
cônes une un peu plus importante et plus
rural pour partager on va avoir
prochainement des déformations avec le
gign sur le la posture à avoir face à
des incivilités et donc j'ai fait plein
de collègues de deux communes rurales
qui vont venir sur notre commune pour
pouvoir pour pouvoir se former et
consomme tous ensemble et qu'on échange
justement sur les pratiques qu'on peut
avoir
sur nos différents territoires donc
voilà après il ya forcément des
difficultés mais c'est surtout que on
garde toujours à l'esprit le fait qu' il
ya du progrès pour permettre à tout le
monde de vivre ensemble et c'est
formidable mais écoutez merci je ne
trouve pas de venir à lyon parce que je
crois que là disons au pub merci
infiniment bertron millions de dinars
gayraud merci beaucoup plus de 1000 yens
je crois qu'on aura on aura l'occasion
évidemment de reparler de tous ces
sujets parce que on touche là peut-être
aussi c'est ça qui est important
la société que de demain quelle quelle
sauce il dans quelle société on veut
vivre demain et je crois que ces villes
nous montre aussi d'aider des exemples
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup à tous et
très vite l'université des mères
continuent
[Musique]